como mínimo
[Música]
el príncipe andrew de reino unido llegó
a un acuerdo con virginia y ufre en la
demanda en la que se le acusa de haber
abusado sexualmente de ella cuando tenía
17 años el acuerdo incluye una donación
millonaria del hijo de la reina isabel
2a a la fundación de joffré amplia
ampliamos desde nueva york
el expresidente hondureño juan orlando
hernández afirmó que está listo para
colaborar con eeuu que lo pidió en
extradición por supuestos delitos de
narcotráfico cometidos entre los años
2004 y 2012
canciller alemán olaf scholz dio la
bienvenida a la retirada crucial de
tropas rusas en la frontera con ucrania
iniciada por su homólogo ruso vladimir
putin ambos insistieron en la vía
diplomática para evitar la guerra
tenemos reporte desde berlín
bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
france 24 soy rodrigo sedano y es un
gusto acompañarlos empezamos esta
emisión en eeuu porque una corte de
manhattan anunció un acuerdo entre el
príncipe andrew y virginia giuffré en la
demanda en la que se le acusa de haber
abusado sexualmente de ella cuando tenía
17 años el acuerdo incluye una donación
millonaria del hijo de la reina isabel
segunda del reino unido a la fundación
de joffré sin especificar el monto
nuestra corresponsal en nueva yor mab en
sala nos ampliará la información
si el príncipe andrés de inglaterra
acaba de llegar a un acuerdo económico
extrajudicial con virginia you free
quien le había demandado por abuso
sexual así lo acaba de informar a través
de un comunicado hace menos de una hora
el tribunal de manhattan que está
llevando este caso violín giuffré
demandó al príncipe andrés por abuso
sexual en ese entramado de tráfico
sexual de menores del multimillonario
fallecido jeffrey epstein y el principio
andrés lo ha negado siempre pero ahora
van a poner fin a este proceso con este
acuerdo entre ambos según un comunicado
que han presentado ambas partes van a
presentar una carta de desestimación del
caso en un periodo de 30 días y cuál va
a ser la cuantía de esa indemnización de
ese acuerdo económico es algo que se
desconoce que va a permanecer
confidencial aunque sí que se ha dicho
en ese comunicado que el príncipe andrés
donará a la fundación donará un dinero a
la fundación de virginia you free en
apoyo a las víctimas por abuso sexual en
este comunicado los abogados del duque
de york también y cito textualmente que
el príncipe lamenta su asociación con el
fallecido multimillonario jeffrey
einstein y elogia la valentía de los
demandantes y su fuerza por denunciar
públicamente estos casos además ha dicho
que va a demostrar su arrepentimiento
apoyando a las víctimas y apoyando sus
derechos de todas estas víctimas de
tráfico y abuso sexual la embajada de
estados unidos en honduras reveló que
acusa al ex presidente hondureño juan
orlando hernández de tres delitos
relacionados con el narcotráfico y el
tráfico de armas entre los años 2004 y
2012 recordemos que su hermano fue
condenado en nueva york' por delitos
similares hernández siempre ha negado
las acusaciones por narcotráfico pero su
hermano fue condenado por una corte de
nueva york por este delito
las acusaciones de corrupción pesan cada
vez más sobre juan orlando hernández la
solicitud oficial de detención de eeuu
sólo tres semanas después de abandonar
la presidencia marcan un nuevo capítulo
tras años de especulaciones sobre sus
vínculos con el narcotráfico que siempre
ha negado
reitero mi rechazo total en nombre del
pueblo hondureño al señalamiento que
nuestro país es un arco estado
porque los avances en la lucha contra
este flagelo han sido hechos y no
palabras reconocidos y aplaudidos
internacionalmente pero los indicios de
la fiscalía de nueva york parecen
indicar lo contrario y acusar al ex
mandatario de conspirar en un caso de
tráfico de drogas de utilizar los
beneficios de la droga para su ascenso
político y facilitar rutas de
narcotráfico una vez en el poder
acusaciones que el gobierno
estadounidense corroboró al anunciar que
el político figura en una de sus listas
de corrupción
eeuu está promoviendo la transparencia y
la rendición de cuentas en centroamérica
al hacer públicas las restricciones de
visas impuestas al expresidente de
honduras juan orlando hernández debido a
acciones corruptas nadie está por encima
de la ley todo esto después de que la
justicia estadounidense lo vinculará con
el caso de su hermano juan antonio
condenado a cadena perpetua por
intermediar en grandes sobornos de
narcotraficantes y facilitar el envío de
droga
increíble
que los testimonios falsos de asesinos
confesos se han escuchado de valorados
de esa forma en su defensa el ex
presidente siempre ha descalificado los
testimonios de los narcotraficantes como
falsos y vengativos no obstante tras
condenar a su hermano la fiscalía
neoyorquina señaló un claro caso de
tráfico de drogas patrocinado por el
estado hondureño de la capital de
argentina buenos aires ha sido el lugar
elegido por diversas organizaciones
sociales de izquierda para marchar en
petición de mayor asistencia social y
más trabajo por parte del gobierno la
movilización llega a días después de que
el gobierno decidiera no ampliar los
planes de empleo en el marco de la
negociación del pago de la deuda con el
fmi nuestro corresponsal en buenos
aires- natalio cos hoy nos daban más
temprano a los detalles
miles de personas marchan en el centro
de la ciudad de buenos aires- en esta
protesta convocada por organizaciones
sociales no alineadas por el gobierno
nacional estas organizaciones sociales
al igual que las que son cercanas al
gobierno del presidente alberto
fernández tienen entre sus tareas la de
distribuir los planes sociales que
entrega el estado nacional algo que es
especialmente clave e importante en un
país con una pobreza que alcanza el 40
por ciento de la población en esta
marcha entre otras cosas lo que están
reclamando es más fondos para estos
planes sociales y también están mirando
a un posible acuerdo con el fondo
monetario internacional con la
desconfianza de que ese acuerdo lleve a
un ajuste un recorte en las partidas de
los planes sociales esta marcha que
también se realiza en otras partes del
país es una especie de convocatoria
previa a una más grande que se espera
para el 11 y 12 de marzo cuando también
se espera que jacques se conozcan los
detalles de un eventual acuerdo con el
fondo monetario y se sepa
o no va a tocar especialmente las
partidas vinculadas con los planes
sociales el jefe de la policía de canadá
renunció en medio de las críticas por la
que es calificada de inacción contra las
protestas que paralizaron a la capital
ottawa entretanto el primer ministro de
canadá justin trudeau anunció la
activación de la ley de emergencia
debido a la situación de orden público
pero qué efecto tendrá la ley de
emergencia en las protestas de anti
vacunas que son minoría en canadá veamos
el lunes el primer ministro josh
instruido invocó la ley de emergencia
que otorga un poder sin precedentes al
gobierno federal inversis a la ley de
emergencias es algo que no se ha
utilizado nunca pero existe por una
razón invocar la ley de emergencias
nunca es lo primero que debe hacer un
gobierno ni siquiera lo segundo la ley
debe utilizarse con moderación y como
último recurso el padre de trudeau
pierre elliott trudeau declaró la
emergencia nacional con la ley de
medidas de guerra en respuesta al
terrorismo pero no a los disturbios de
civiles hace 50 años cuando un grupo de
separatistas de quebec secuestró a un
diplomático y a un ministro de la
provincia todo especificó que la ley
sería geográficamente específica y
limitada en el tiempo mientras los
camioneros protestan por tercera semana
contra las medidas de la pandemia en la
capital la medida dada a las fuerzas de
seguridad un poder más contundente para
restablecer el orden público dándoles la
autoridad de restringir los
desplazamientos prohibir las reuniones
públicas e incautar los camiones y otros
vehículos utilizados en los bloqueos en
una medida más económica el ministro de
finanzas dijo que él federal congelará
las cuentas bancarias de las personas
involucradas en las protestas ilegales y
cooperará con los poderes de recaudación
de fondos para una mayor transparencia
ya que el convoy de la libertad recaudó
millones en línea entre tanto los
camioneros parecen imperturbables
en realidad no no nos importa lo que
están haciendo en el parlamento queremos
que nos devuelvan nuestras libertades
las que teníamos en 2019
en el primer fin de semana y me fui a
casa y vi las noticias y escuché a turdó
mentir mintió y me molestó tanto que
dejé mi trabajo regresé y no me iré
hasta que ganemos
la declaración de emergencia entra en
vigor inmediatamente pero el parlamento
debe aprobar en el plazo de una semana
el canciller alemán olaf scholz se
reunió este martes en moscú con su
homólogo ruso vladimir putin desde allí
el presidente ruso anunció la retirada
parcial de las tropas situadas cerca de
la frontera con ucrania e insistió en
que no tiene intención intención de ir a
la guerra solos saludó la noticia
escuchemos sus palabras
y las opciones diplomáticas están lejos
de estar agotadas una tarea ahora debe
ser trabajar con decisión y con valor
hacia una resolución pacífica de esta
crisis ahora estamos escuchando que
algunas tropas van a retirarse así que
esa es una buena señal esperamos que
esto continúe
estamos listos para seguir trabajando
juntos estamos listos para continuar el
camino de las negociaciones pero todas
las preguntas deben ser todos los
asuntos como dije antes deben ser
considerados como un todo gracias madre
8 cumplir la relación económica entre
alemania y rusia podría ser clave a la
hora de solucionar el conflicto en
ucrania uno de los principales temas que
trataron los dirigentes de ambos países
fue el futuro del gasoducto nord stream
2 nuestro corresponsal en berlín tomas
sparrow pudo analizar esta relación
la visita de olaf scholz el canciller
alemán a moscú este martes fue
importante no solamente por el riesgo
que existe actualmente de una posible
guerra en europa sino también por el rol
relevante pero muy controversial que
juega alemania en toda esta situación es
un rol que tiene que ver claramente con
el vínculo económico estrecho entre
berlín y moscú y de manera muy
particular con el gasoducto nord stream
2 que ya está completado aún no está en
funciones pero une precisamente a rusia
y alemania- si vienen quienes consideran
como lo hacen varios aliados políticos
de alemania que no son dos deja
demasiado vulnerable a europa y le da
demasiado poder a moscú también hay
quienes creen que precisamente por esos
vínculos económicos estrechos alemania
pueden jugar un rol clave en la búsqueda
de una solución negociada a este
conflicto esas diferentes miradas
quedaron en evidencia en la rueda de
prensa que sostuvieron olaf scholz y
vladimir putin en moscú así como también
quedaron en evidencia las dos partes de
la estrategia política alemana por un
lado que alemania seguirá buscando
canales de comunicación para hablar con
ruso por ejemplo el formato de normandía
en el que francia y alemania negocian
con ucrania y con rusia pero por el otro
lado que alemania está claramente del
lado de sus aliados políticos en la
unión europea y en la otan y que actuará
en conjunto con ellos si rusia decide
invadir ucrania
en kabul la capital de afganistán
cientos de afganos salieron a las calles
a protestar contra la decisión de eeuu
de reducir a la mitad la ayuda al país
asiático de los siete mil millones de
dólares presupuestados por la casa
blanca la mitad irán ahora destinados a
las víctimas de los atentados del 11 de
septiembre de 2001 nueva york la
decisión llega a seis meses después de
la llegada de los talibanes al poder
precisamente veamos cómo ha cambiado el
país para las mujeres con la caída de
kabul
en el momento de su primer matrimonio
fátima tenía siete años y su marido
ochenta cuando él murió se volvió a
casar con otro hombre y sufrió
violaciones palizas hambre y sólo vio
una forma de salir de su calvario
intenté suicidarme había sido sulfúrico
estuve hospitalizado durante un mes y
medio va a darse baja en estos médicos
me pidieron que volviera más tarde para
una operación
no me dejó ir al hospital
finalmente fátima huyó de su casa y vive
escondida en unos de los pocos refugios
para mujeres que siguen abiertos donde
teme perder su lugar en cualquier
momento sin embargo los talibanes
afirman haber cambiado a finales de
noviembre su portavoz dijo que las
mujeres maltratadas podían acudir a los
tribunales lo que esta joven que también
vive en un refugio no cree hot maquilla
madden de ser versionada gordon vine
aquí con muchos sueños esperaba
conseguir mi divorcio encontrar un
trabajo y llevar mi propia vida pero
cuando los talibanes tomaron el poder
todos mis sueños se hicieron añicos y
ahora mi divorcio es imposible los
jueces han abandonado afganistán los
abogados también antes del regreso de
los talibanes el sistema de protección
de las mujeres ya era muy imperfecto en
afganistán pero los pocos logros
conseguidos se van desmoronando uno tras
otro el ministerio de asuntos de la
mujer que llevaba 20 años funcionando ha
sido suprimido y sustituido por el
ministerio de la promoción de la virtud
y prevención del vicio yang el balance
está el wind on en the house es la
violencia doméstica sigue existiendo en
los hogares las familias y los pueblos
pero lo único que ha cambiado es que
estas mujeres saben que en cuanto salgan
de sus casas si lo hacen serán detenidas
y enviadas a la cárcel y ahí se acaba
todo
[Música]
las tradiciones patriarcales la pobreza
y la falta de educación siempre han
obstaculizado los derechos de las
mujeres en afganistán según la onu el 87
por ciento de las mujeres afganas han
sufrido algún tipo de violencia física
sexual o psicológica
hasta que este repaso de la actualidad
internacional sigan con nosotros
[Música]